[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
he's George Kittle the Niners tight end
four-time pro bowler and uh tight end
University begins its third year
three-day event at Vandy in Nashville
from June 20th through the 22nd George
says back on the program we haven't
played the how much can you bench game
in a while how about we do this with
George how much do you think Max one rep
Todd what do you think for uh George
425 425. holy moly okay
Seton safe
3 45. all right Marvin that's respectful
Marvin 385
385. okay
Paulie I'm gonna go four even based off
his reaction four even
all right
I'm gonna go
I'm gonna go 390.
wow how much can George Kittle bench
press one time
Max rep is what
uh
um I haven't done a Max trip in about
two years but I think it was I think I
got 405. 405. okay I think I got it once
now I did have like one board on my
chest just for that but I'm gonna take
it okay
right what's the most you've seen
somebody bench press
I watched Shaq Thompson the guard uh he
works on me in Nashville and the bar was
bending on both sides as he benched it
and he was benching more than I squat so
and that's I squat a lot so that was
kind of humbling experience to see him
do that well what are we talking about
500 600 yeah summer it was it was
absolutely disgusting yeah over it was
over 550 I'm pretty sure
500. who would bench the most at tight
end University
hmm it's a good question
um
you know my first name that came in my
head was like Luke stalker
old Titans tight end big he's a big big
stocky guy I work out with him too I
would say him or
um Hayden Hurst is look he's a strong
dude he's he's got some girth to him I
would definitely say hey he's definitely
a strong guy when did the tight end
position change
uh like from being an extra left tackle
yeah
um you know I I think there's guys that
started the change from Tony G to
Antonio Gates Shannon sharp like guys
that were ahead of their time uh because
nowadays if you have a tight end that
can only run block and he can't run
routes he's only playing like 10 snaps a
game and so to be able to play the you
know if you want to play every single
step if you want to get paid like a top
guy you have to be able to do everything
and you have to get out there and run
routes
um but I think it was like the biggest I
think
um Gronk and Kelsey and uh like Jimmy
Graham was kind of like the he was like
right before Gronk and Kelsey and I
think they both really changed the game
which is their passing because with the
receiving stuff just because once you
have a tight end that can dominate the
middle of a field going against nickels
and linebackers or you have to use two
guys to cover him and then you open up
all the outside guys I think that
completely changed game so I mean I
would say like seven to seven to ten
years ago I think the game's completely
changed and I think it just keeps
getting faster and faster with the Titan
position yeah I go back to Mike Ditka
and John Mackey those were guys who
could break open and break off of five
ten yard pass reception and they could
take it a long distance Kellen Winslow
might have been the first athletic tight
end and almost felt like that was a wide
receiver but uh Kellen Winslow was
probably the first one that I remember
and then as far as getting paid
you know wide receivers get paid where
do the tight ends sort of fit how do you
get paid as a tight end and where you
can get a wide receiver money
well um if you look back at it in the
last six years I'm pretty sure Travis
Kelsey is leading the NFL in receiving
yards and he makes half of what uh our
top wide receivers are making and that
doesn't make sense to me and so I'll
continually be a vocal uh voice for
tight ends uh to get paid more money but
um you know what that's just the battle
we're fighting that's kind of the point
of Titan use is to elevate the position
so more guys have an opportunity to go
out there and secure a bag and to raise
that uh to raise that pay grade for all
of us yeah but you guys are so important
now thank you but it's like running
backs though George you know running
backs are still important you know
they're catching they got to catch 80
passes in rush for a thousand yards they
have a short career and they don't get
any respect whatsoever why is that
oh Dan you're getting me fired up today
man that's crazy uh you know what you
look at a guy like Christian McCaffrey
who one season had over a thousand yards
receiving and a thousand yards rushing
and uh you know I think he's his
contract might be 16 million and which
is awesome and I'm not going to complain
about making millions of dollars I'm not
but when you compare it to other guys in
the league
um you know there's wide receivers who
are second string wide receivers making
20 or making 18 million and this is a
guy like Chris mccaff who are uh Dalvin
cook for 1 000 yards seasons in a row
he's 27 years old he's got at least
three to five left in them at a high
level in my opinion
um but like you just look at Christian
like every single play he affects the
defense even if he's running a wide
route to the side there's two guys
looking at him which is opening up the
middle of the field for everybody else
and I'm not saying that the Niners
should pay Christian work after more
money you know I hope they do he's
fantastic but just the running back
position itself is very disrespected
because the amount of carries and
touches that these guys get ever every
single game and
um and like another thing is like an
argument is oh running backs get hurt a
lot you know they're they're they're
whatever like their livelihood in the
NFL is not as long as people I argue
that with obj just came off of two
seasoning surgeries and he's making 18
million dollars so don't don't say it's
injuries don't say that it's about the
player and obj is fantastic and I you
know I wish him success but like if
you're gonna pay a guy who's coming off
two surgeries 18 million how can the
best running back in the NFL make 16.
and then how can the best Titans NFL
make 15 or less he's crazy George Kittle
the Niners tight end four uh four-time
pro bowler explain Cooper cup
oh
um
he's like a calm sound assassin
technician he just does everything right
I see how I've seen him work before I
hang out with him a couple times
fantastic dude uh family dude but like
just his his intent with what he does is
pretty I think that's what makes him so
good is every time he touches a field
his intent is to be great and be the
best on the field and that's what it
looks like on film
um and you see everything that he does
he can run out of route on anybody
whether it's a corner safety nickel
linebacker it doesn't matter who's
covering him he can be double covered
and he's also really smart you see those
post game interviews where he's talking
about the the fire Blitz off the side
he's hot off of this and all that stuff
which is you know I and you know I can
uh I see that as well I just don't
explain in the same terms as he does but
he uh the way that he breaks that stuff
down it's really impressive so you know
that every time he's running a route
he's seeing the whole defense and he's
seen hey The Leverage is outside I know
that it's probably warm plugs when I run
this route I need to create a little bit
more width on the outside so when I do
break inside there's there's a window
for Stafford to hit me and you can see
that thought process when he watches
film and uh he's fantastic I mean what
can you say about that the Triple Crown
a year ago so you know I hope he comes
back healthy and just dominates again
except for against the Niners what was
it like in the Huddle when you were
playing Philadelphia in the playoffs
foreign
well the whole process there that you
start out you got to feel good Brock
Purdy we're we're feeling good about our
team
then he gets hurt
and and then what do you what are you
thinking now and then when McCaffrey
comes in as your quarterback what are
you thinking
uh you know what I was incredibly
confident before the game uh Purdy was
eight no he's hot our officers averaging
30 points a game number one defense in
the league uh so I mean I think all of
our confidence was Sky High
um Brock gets hurt uh Josh Johnson comes
in no
I play with Josh that was my second
second and a half year playing with Josh
Johnson uh definitely have gotten a lot
of reps with them you know one of the
years we played together I was coming
off the IR and so I got a bunch of reps
with him no he can throw a ball Nobody
Knows the offense so still confident
um you know I mean honestly I'm still
really confident as long as someone's
back there can throw a football I know
that we can still run our offense
um and then you know once Josh got hurt
which was really unfortunate about was
that like a drive into the third quarter
and then Christian comes in or Brock
Verde comes in and he can't throw a
left-handed which I'm very disappointed
about and hey I was telling John Legend
we should draft quarterbacks you can
throw both arms why not seems like a
simple thing to do you know I have to
run block pass bro and run around why
can't a quarterback throw arms all right
Fair Point yeah I know thanks Dan
um but so I mean it was the whole just
it just kind of sucked it just I mean
you look at guys and especially in the
second when when we're out of
quarterbacks we're just on a running
back where our
Cormac who they can't throw you're just
kind of like well you know that we're
gonna get 11 in the box they're gonna
Blitz every single play there's
literally nothing that we can do there's
no trick play that we can run
um we're already down 14 points like
it was uh it was definitely dying to
slow death that's about that's about
what it was and I mean there's not much
we could do differently about it um you
know I had people hit me up like hey you
know you just got to work harder and
that's how you guys are going to win
next year and it's just like I don't
know winning 12 games straight and then
losing two quarterbacks doesn't really
feel like I need to work harder it just
feels like I need to be a little bit
luckier yeah my quarterback stays
healthy so you know there's that um
nothing that you know I don't really
linger with it too I thought I played a
pretty good game uh nothing really I
could have done differently at that
point too but uh it is what it is you
know are you expecting Brock to be
starting week one
oh yeah I am I mean if you win eight
games in a row it's hard to bench that
guy no I mean health-wise health-wise oh
yeah yeah yeah yeah I do I think I mean
he's been throwing I think he looks good
I've seen him throw once or twice
um he's confident he's in a good place
mentally uh and physically so I'm
excited about that you know
um like I said we were rolling within
averaging 30 points a game so why you
mean looking forward to it what do you
hope these tight ends get out of tight
end University
foreign
let's see the main things I hope they
get is first I hope then like when a
rookie finishes his first game uh
against a team that he is is comfortable
going across the field and talking to
other tight ends and to feel like
they're not alone out here and they're
not just like at you know out at Sea by
themselves and if they want to they can
text me they can text Travis Kelsey they
can have Greg Olsen
um they hit up Hayden Hurst they can hit
up Dallas Goddard and ask him questions
it's just kind of building a Brotherhood
of you know whether it's support or you
know just friendship that's kind of my
biggest goal with the Titan uh after
that I hope guys come in and they learn
a thing or two about whether it's Run
game running routes or just your mindset
approaching certain and individual plays
whether it's a game or a game week it's
just learning how to play the tight end
position at a high level that's why I
hope to get out of it
yeah I think it's pretty cool
quarterbacks seem to have this
fraternity and I don't know if other
positions do but you're you're trying to
create that fraternal nature with with
tight ends this is how Pros do it this
is what's going to happen your first
year this is where you know you need to
improve you know those kind of things so
it's it's sort of a seminar tutorial a
PowerPoint of how to play the position
it's pretty cool pretty cool
thanks Dan no it's fun and you know this
year we got uh gronks coming through
really excited about that oh
keg stands
yeah we'll see hey you said fraternity
um we got that um and then what well
actually one of my favorite guests we
got coming this year is uh Jordan Reed
and he's going to teach releases uh
which I'm really excited about so we
have like a whole highlight reel of his
top releases and he's just gonna talk
about his mindset hey this guy's pressed
I've been inside release route these are
the thought my thought process going
into these releases and well I don't
know if everybody can do Jordan reads
releases because he's one of the
freakiest athletes I've ever seen it'll
still be fun to be able to see that and
be able to kind of apply that to your
game so yeah it's got to be a good time
Will Ferrell is uh Frank the Tank he you
know so Gronk would be frank the tank
from Will Ferrell and old school where
there's going to be keg stands and yeah
it could get loose here at tight end
University
you know
um
We're Not Gonna not have a good time I
will say that
we're gonna have some fun okay and then
you have Partners there event Partners
to to help you as well so they'll be
involved in this as well yeah you know I
mean the whole thing the reason that we
can do all this is because of our
sponsors
um Sharman is one of our big sponsors
you can see that right here see on my
t-shirt right here okay
um you know Sherman tight ends
it kind of goes hand in hand let's just
be honest uh so they're you know big
partner uh Bridgestone is a huge part of
partner for us too they're back for year
three
um we're actually cool too we always
like try to give back at some point
during Titan U so about 20 of the 75
guys uh we're gonna meet up with about
150 high school kids and 50 middle
schoolers and talk about literacy and
why reading is important why school is
so important so to be able to give back
to the National Community don't bring
grunk to that you know I think see one
of the things you know Calvin and Hobbes
yeah
all right so I'm a big Calvin the Hobbs
guy got him tatted on my hand right
there I know so uh but of course you do
with the fifth and sixth graders we're
gonna go through a bunch of Calvin and
Hobbs books so I think Ron could
participate
uh let's see we got
um Raising Canes one of my favorite
favorite chicken restaurants I'm
obsessed with the raising cane sauce so
really excited to see them back and um
you know Levi's because every tight end
looks great and apparently isn't that
what you're doing yeah let's see what
you're doing I think we need to have a
Long Snapper you because you know those
guys are forgotten you know there's a
science to being a Long Snapper and you
only get mentioned when you screw up
dude I know isn't that brutal the only
time you could have you could have like
10 game winning ones a in a year no one
will say your name once and one mildly
bad snap and you're off you're out of
the NFL what should I what's it like in
the Huddle when somebody gets called for
holding and you have to bring back a
long touchdown and then they announce
that holding number 73 and then he has
to come back into the huddle anybody say
anything
I had one of those this year it was ah
you know what I'm not allowed to say
that it's a bad call but I disagree with
the call okay
um and I had a holding call and a touch
of my Elijah Mitchell we're playing the
Saints and I think I was blocking the
guy and he tried to move and he tripped
over my foot and so he kind of fell a
little bit and the back judge threw a
flag on me it was like a 50-yard
touchdown run and they're like yeah
holding 85. I say trip Williams next to
me goes don't even think about it
terrible call don't worry about it I'm
like thank you Trent Williams I feel
great about myself now
fun there play nice at tight end
University at uh Vandy the 20th through
the 22nd he's uh George Kittle thank you
George good to talk to you again dick
ask you a question real quick yeah
uh how is it like hitting Stone Cold
Steve Austin with a chair
it was very nerve-wracking I had the
chair right over there in the corner yes
um he had a pad uh it was probably an
eight by eight pad on his back and he
said just make sure you hit me right
there and I go okay so I have a chair I
have a folding chair and I smack him and
then he goes you got to hit me harder
than that
and I hit him again he got harder and
then I we did like five takes the last
one that I did I swung so hard with the
metal chair you can see the paper on the
bulletin board like flying I hit him so
hard and he goes that yeah can I have
another one Dan in in the commercial I
did and I hit him again there's a big
dent in it but I had to hit him right on
that pad and I thought oh my God if I
miss and it glances up and you know
nerve-wracking nerve-wracking but he was
so much fun in a great Sport and it
probably took us 30 minutes to do that
but when he said you got to hit me
harder than that and I went all right
I'm going to and uh you know we I went
all in on it
oh that's awesome thanks for sharing me
good dude all right thank you George
to see you guys that's tight end
University George Kittle always good to
have him on